if you google Conan in any country that
I'm the first thing that comes up all
right which is as it should be except in
one country Japan okay yeah please let's
not get angry here and it makes what wow
this crowd okay you're ready to go anti
Japan
I just learned in Japan the first thing
that comes up if you google Conan is a
manga an anime character named and this
is true Detective Conan this is the
first thing that comes up Detective
Conan there he is he's a man who's
trapped in a child's body and solves
crimes yeah
trapped in a child's body Hey so I was
like what is this all about
never else the world Conan I come up
except Japan Detective Conan so I
decided to learn more about this
Detective Conan character the results
were very interesting like me Japanese
Conan has long skinny legs okay he has
distinctive hair he always wears a suit
spends all day asking people questions
and his extremely cartoonish and again a
man trapped in a child's body Plus just
for reference this is a picture of me as
a schoolboy I don't know if you notice
any similarities now let me go further
not only that detective conan was
created in 1994 what a coincidence
that's the year after I went on the air
well detective conan has become so
popular in japan there are now Conan
live-action movies conan cafes and this
really blew my mind and it's absolutely
true an actual city that's been renamed
conan town yes here's here's a map of
conan town here's one of the town's
trains they even have a statue of
detective conan in the center of town
yeah making the same kind of
douche-baggy expression that I've been
doing for years now someone's been
making a lot of money off the Asian
version of me for 24 years now listen
I'm a reasonable person and I think we
can make this whole ugly business go
away for several trillion yen Wow
yeah in fact to be specific I think
three trillion yen would be appropriate
don't you three TS
a lot of yen gelada yen now don't make
me lawyer up Japan I know you guys are
watching so here's the deal if you want
to keep this thing out of court send a
check for three trillion yen to the more
famous Conan 4-thousand Warner Boulevard
Burbank California
nine one five two two
[Applause]
you